Cuál es el panorama ahora mismo de la
lucha contra el cáncer en este momento
en América Latina
gracias Sí pues el cáncer ocupa el
primer lugar en incidencia de mortalidad
en la mayoría de los países del Mundo
sabemos que a mayor índice de desarrollo
humano mayor incidencia de cáncer esto
quiere decir que con mayor expectativa
de vida mayor ingreso per cápita
se va vamos a tener un mayor crecimiento
en la en el número de casos y en las
tasas de incidencia de cada país de
acuerdo con las proyecciones que se han
estudiado en Latinoamérica vamos a tener
un incremento importante que se aproxima
más o menos al 45% en los próximos años
en los próximos 10 años en Latinoamérica
esto por porque los países
latinoamericanos enfrentan Un aumento en
la expectativa de vida de las mujeres
qué desafío siguen pendientes en medio
de esta época en la que prácticamente
los esfuerzos de la salud pública se han
centrado bien de centrarse en la
pandemia de hobbit 19
sí la pandemia que hoy 19 nos mostró que
hubo un descenso en la participación de
las mujeres en los programas de
detección temprana se dejaron de hacer
mamografías las mujeres dejaron de
acudir a sus chequeos a los médicos Y
por supuesto se registró un incremento
en el diagnóstico de los casos en
estadios avanzados de la enfermedad en
donde todos sabemos que es más difícil
la curación más difícil y más costoso el
tratamiento Entonces los grandes
desafíos que se observan en
Latinoamérica es que como tenemos
grandes desigualdades en el acceso a las
tecnologías hay una mayor oferta de
servicios de mamografía y de
especialistas oncólogos clínicos y
cirujanos para la atención de las
mujeres con cáncer en las grandes
ciudades en donde hay un mayor riesgo
las mujeres que viven en municipios
intermedios o lejanos en donde de todos
modos el riesgo es menor tienen mayores
dificultades en el acceso a las
tecnologías Entonces el reto para
Latinoamérica
tener una unos modelos de atención que
le permitan a las mujeres tener acceso a
las posibilidades de diagnóstico y de
tratamiento
Creen ustedes Los profesionales de la
salud que esta campaña está perdiendo
algo de su identidad de la identidad en
medio del extremo quizás de la del
extremo comercial al que se le ha
llevado por parte de estas campañas
Sí claro las campañas han hecho un
efecto en la población puesto que antes
la el cáncer era sinónimo de muerte y
las mujeres incluso tenían miedo de
participar en las actividades de
detección temprana como hacerse la
mamografía y ahora hay una mayor
conciencia de que es una enfermedad en
la que todas las mujeres del mundo
estamos en riesgo y que una vez superado
el miedo de la detección es posible
Tener una curación y una supervivencia
por encima de 20 años o incluso morir
por otras causas Señor por recordarlo
una vez más Cuáles son las
recomendaciones de salud la
recomendación es que hacen ustedes a la
hora de una detección previa del cáncer
de mama
toda mujer joven debe palparse sus senos
regularmente particularmente en la ducha
conocerlo porque los senos cambian todos
los meses por el ciclo menstrual tienen
una contextura un poco granulosa
Entonces es muy importante el
autoconocimiento la palpación para poder
identificar cualquier causa a mayor edad
mayor riesgo de que esta que haya una
patología maligna y particularmente para
las mujeres por encima de los 40 años es
importante que de manera sistemática y
anual la mujer se haga examinar sus
senos permita que el médico palpe sus
senos así no tenga ninguna ningún signo
ninguna molestia Frente a cualquier
molestia o signo como puede ser cambios
en la contextura de la piel y el que
tenga la apariencia de naranja un pezón
retraído cambios en la colaboración en
la comunicación hay que ir
inmediatamente al médico y para que haga
los exámenes complementarios de y al
iniciar el tratamiento si es necesario y
toda mujer mayor de 50 años debe hacerse
la mamografía cada dos años hasta los 65
años